people are talking about uh robert
caldini
robert caldini wrote a book
called
influence and influences a book on
persuasion
it is one of the best books uh one of
the best business and skill books ever
written
and i can recommend it for everybody
who's listening to this to read it
what caldini talks about is how you
persuade people how you convince people
to do things what are the tricks what
are the strategies
and it turns out that most of these
strategies work really well
even if you know that they're being used
on you they're that good because we as
human humans are emotionally and
behaviorally hardwired through evolution
to fall for these strategies
and
the book is called influence by robert
kaldini c-i-a-l-d-i-n-i
and the key takeaway in caldini is class
r
s r c-l-a-s-s-r
an acronym and it stands for
uh how
you persuade people
the c is consistency
people want to be consistent with their
past actions so if they did something
before then they kind of wrap that into
their identity and they want to be
consistent and do that kind of action
again so example uh
benjamin franklin used to have this
trick where if he wanted someone who
didn't like him if he had a social enemy
he would go to them and he would ask
them to borrow a book and it was kind of
awkward because especially back when he
was alive books were rare
books were expensive and books were
things to be treasured but at the same
time he always wanted to teach people so
he would say let me borrow a book from
you and if somebody said sure you know
here's the book and they were his enemy
they'd feel a little awkward and they'd
loan him the book then later when he
came back and returned the book and was
nice to them again they would they would
think well i loaned him the book in the
past therefore i i wouldn't loan a book
to someone i didn't like therefore i
must like him so just to be consistent
with their past action they would like
him more so that's how consistency works
liking is obvious that's an l in class r
that if somebody likes you they're more
likely to be persuaded by you so just be
nice to them
a is for authority so for example you're
more likely to listen to a doctor about
medical advice than you are about a
non-doctor so that's why you have the
infomercial saying you know recommended
by ex-dentists or why doctors um
the s the next s is scarcity which is
you know there's only a few of these
left it's disappearing grab it fast now
it's like the used car salesman saying
this is the last one i have left left a
lot
the second s stands for social proof
which is monkey c monkey do
so when uh
you know if you see your friends doing
something then you will do it the
simplest example of this is just go
stand on the street and start looking up
and pretty soon other people around you
will all be looking up
and then r is a reciprocity which is
people always want to repay you and
sometimes we can't do the math on what
things are worth so for example the hare
krishnas in the airport will come up to
you and they'll give you uh you know uh
they'll give you a flower or they'll
give you like a copy of the bhagavad
gita and then they'll ask for a donation
uh and the donation is often like out of
proportion to what the book was worth so
that's kind of the code
that caldini gets to his book class r
that's kind of what you need to remember
uh scott adams has a great blog where he
goes in much more detail about more
modern techniques of persuasion
including ones that trump uses such as
linguistic kill shots and assuming the
sale uh
and uh you know anchoring in
negotiations and so on so i think
persuasion is one of those foundational
skills that everybody should learn at
least the basic theories around it and
robert caldini and scott adams blogs are
probably the two places that i will
start let's talk about unity which is
the the new one that you've added to the
book the seventh principle what is it
how does it work
it works for a communicator in the
following way if that communicator can
arrange for us to see him or her
as one of us
that is as someone who shares an
identity with them in some kind of
important way
right like a tribal identity it can be a
tr yes tribal identity but it can be
something uh le i'll give you an example
of a a study that was done on a college
campus researchers asked a
young woman college-aged woman to stand
on a heavily trafficked part of campus
and ask people to donate to a good cause
i think it was the united way
and she was getting some contributions
if
she said before she made the request
one
thing
right
which was
i'm a student here too would you give
the united way
donations went up 400 percent
i'm one of you i'm one of you i'm of you
i'm not just like you in style or
preferences or those are things
no
i'm of you
then people will say yes and this is a
superpower in error causing
psychological tendency
bias from consistency and commitment
tendency including the tendency to avoid
or promptly resolve cognitive dissonance
includes the self-confirmation tendency
of all conclusions particularly
expressed conclusions and with a special
persistence for conclusions that are
hard-won
but what i'm saying here is that the
human mind is a lot like the human egg
and the human egg has a shut off device
when sperm gets in it shuts down so the
next one can't get in
the human mind has a big tendency of the
same sort
and here again it doesn't just catch
ordinary mortals it catches
the deans of physics according to max
planck the really innovative important
new physics was never really accepted by
the old guard instead a new guard came
along that was less broadblocked by its
previous conclusions
and if max planck's crowd
had this
consistency and
commitment tendency that
kept their old inclusions intact in
spite of disconfirming evidence you can
imagine
what the crowd that you and i are part
of
behaves like
and of course if you make a public
disclosure of your conclusion you're
pounding it in
to your own head many of these students
that are screaming at us you know they
aren't convincing us but they're
they're forming mental chains for
themselves because what they're shouting
out they're pounding in
and
i think educational institutions that
create a climate where too much of that
goes on
are in a fundamental sense they're
irresponsible institutions
uh it's very important to
not put your brain in chains too young
by what you shout out
uh and all these things like painful
qualifying and initiation rituals and
all those things
pound in your
your commitments
and your ideas
and the chinese brainwashing system
which was for war prisoners which was
way better than anybody else's
they maneuvered people into making tiny
little
commitments and declarations and then
they'd slowly build
that worked way better than torture
[Music]
[Music]
you